I began moving them around and I wanted an arrangement,
you know, where I had a big and a small molecule.
So how did you do it?
Somehow you had to form link bonds.
So here's A and here's T
and I wanted this hydrogen to point directly at this nitrogen.
So I had something like this.
So then I went to the pair and wanted this nitrogen to point to this one,
I went like this.
They look the same.
You can put one right on top of the other.
We knew,
even if we go up to the ceiling, we were building a tiny fraction
of a molecule. A hundred million of these  base pairs in one
molecule, all fitting into this wonderful symmetry which we saw the
morning of February 28th, 1953.